congratulations on jungle cruise
uh the movie's a blast i had such a good
time with it
uh i am confident it's gonna be a huge
hit but before we get into jungle cruise
and a few other things
i have a few other questions um and
they're going to be aimed at john davis
so mr davis i'm going to start with you
okay
you have produced so many movies in your
career but i am curious
what is the white whale that has that
you've never been able to
get to the starting line oh good that's
a good question
that i've been working on so there are
some movies that took me 27 or 28 years
to make but i made the man from uncle
for instance
right there is a movie i've been working
on that i love for 30 years
and we keep getting close i've never
gotten over the top
it's called tricksters in the mad house
and it's about the harlem globetrotters
and in 1947 when they upset the
minneapolis lakers greatest upset in
history basketball
and what was at stake was whether or not
they were going to integrate the game of
basketball in the nba
and it is a great story i love sports
it's a wonderful script i keep getting
close i keep getting close i keep
getting close
that's the one i've never gotten over
even
nowadays with streaming and all the
different people looking for content
is it is it do you feel like now it's
even closer because
of all these people looking you know
every movie
is its own challenge and getting any
movie made
is a challenge sometimes i think we feel
like
we've won um um the the war
we just get the movie made and then we
realized okay now it's got to be really
good and now
people got to go see it right but even
just crossing that finish line
is so complicated and so difficult do
you hold your actors in did you get
an actor big enough the studio's going
to finance it did your director leave is
he taking another movie how do you get
everything lined up
it's just look i can't believe we've
done it 112 times
because it's almost it it's almost a
miracle when something comes together
yeah i think a lot of people i've had
this conversation with other producers
and people that um
don't really understand how the movie
business works would be
dumbfounded at how scheduling can throw
off an entire movie one extra week of
filming
and everything is screwed yeah
exactly sad reality yeah it's very true
so you mentioned man from uncle which is
a movie i love
obviously right now a sequel is not
being made
but i am curious if you go back a few
years did it ever
come up that you guys were serious about
doing a sequel or was it not financially
viable
to actually move forward on another
that's one of those movies where
literally
we had five different directors before
it finally happened
and every time we'd come together it
would come together with a big star and
a big director
and then fall apart and then we'd come
back together with a different star and
a different director
and i think that the cast that we had on
on our movie
would probably make it really hard back
when it first came out
did you guys talk about making a sequel
at all because i love that film
and i was just curious if it ever got
like no we never we never did get around
to
to the sqlizing of that uh jumping into
uh i'm fascinated by the editing room
because ultimately that's where it all
comes together
so you've made as you said over 100
projects
um which film of all of your films went
through the biggest
changes in the editing room from like
what you thought you were going to
deliver to what actually got released
great question because you pivot in
every single movie in the editing room
you shoot a movie
and then you remake it in the editing
room you know people always say movies
never as good as the dailies are as bad
as the first cut
you're actually making a movie three
times you're scripting it you're
shooting it you're cutting it
right each time you're making a
different version of the movie it's
always the case
john and i made a movie with david o
russell and that movie got invented in
the editing room seven different times
because that's his process um
it's every single movie in the editing
room goes to its own process because
then you test the movie with audiences
and then you find out that something
didn't make sense to them
or you test it with an audience and you
can feel them in the room and you
realize
the third act's gonna have to go in a
different way or you realize the end of
the movie
doesn't work so it's a hard question to
answer
because literally every movie i've done
through that process pivot pivot pivot
pivot sometimes we reshoot
you'd be surprised how different a movie
is from the first cut you have until the
last cut
but then you get the rare example like a
movie we did called game night
that aft the first cut of the movie is
98
of what the finished cut of the movie
was uh first cut was was fantastic we
tested it
audiences loved it it tested i think it
was in the high 90s and
mid mid to high 90s in the first test in
the studio went great
i think we swapped out a couple of jokes
uh you know in edit room and then
that was it we locked picture a bunch of
the eddie murphy movies that we made
i think we've made five of them um
because they're comedies
you know there was a lot of when we
tested with audiences and listened to
where they laughed and whatever
there was a lot of you know kind of
re-editing
some reshooting you know they eventually
all ended up the point where they really
really worked they all
you know were very big successes
um you know dolomite funny enough
pretty much um the first cut was the
movie
you know we tightened it a bunch um you
know no reshooting
um kind of no rethinking the script um
so and and the first doolittle um
we did a we did a reshoot and we did a
lot of rethinking and a lot of
reorganizing
i will say that for people that are
watching this interview um who have not
seen dolomite
movies phenomenal and also game night i
mean there's a reason these movies were
worked on the first cut because they're
both fantastic films
thank you it's very sweet thank you and
we and we did a movie
with will smith called a robot and there
was a lot of
rethinking the third act of that right
um
and what ultimately came to be um
made so much more sense um storyline
visually everything than the first cut i
am
so as someone who loves hollywood and
hollywood history
i am curious though if you ever save
like an alt cut of some of these movies
in like a vault
in your office so you have like the
seven different versions of
the david o'russell movie uh somewhere
in a box or is it sort of like
they just don't exist anymore we have
the scripts we definitely have yeah we
have the script
every single script of every movie we've
done
um we have multiple drafts of and we
keep those and we keep them in level
some of them in leather bound um
encasements so they're really kind of
like can be on the shelf and and you
know it looks great and all that stuff
like jungle cruise john and i have seen
that movie
i promise you 25 times maybe 30.
you know um because you watch it again
and again you test it with audiences and
you watch it
and you know then you watch it with the
disney exacts
you know and then you watch it you know
you know in seven other situations and
you're in the editing room always
watching with the director we're in the
editing room
on that movie a lot with drama
re-watching re-watching re-watching the
movie
um just because there's a lot of film
and it's a big movie
at the end of the process you've seen
the movie so many times you don't want
to see it again
you've been producing since i think
since the 80s
john i could be wrong no that's true
right so
i am talking about the 1880s right right
exactly he was working with fritz lang
back in the 20s
in germany um so but i am curious
how has the business changed for you
since then
to the way movies are made now is there
certain elements that are exactly the
same
or has the industry gone through some
sort of radical shift in those
i'm not going to use the amount of
amount of years but this is the amount
of time you've been doing this
four radical shifts and yet it's still
the same
and um when i first started it was the
era of the movie stars and there were a
lot of big movie stars
um and i feel like now we're in the age
where the star is really the ip the star
is really the concept
and there's fewer really big movie stars
and
and and so that's kind of changed and i
started cutting my teeth working with
arnold schwarzenegger
and i did movies with denzel washington
and we did movies with eddie murphy and
sly stallone
and you know in the in those day and
ages
you got a big movie star you attach them
to your script and you were making your
movie
um and that just kind of drove it and
then and then and
and a movie star drove the box office
today it feels like it's become an ip
driven business
and really studios really only want
either
big tentpole blockbuster ip driven
movies
or horror movies they can make for price
it's gotten to be really hard to make
comedies
although we're working on some that we
love um
you know but uh really really really
hard to get comedies made
um and then you know the other kind of
big movement big change is business
became very corporate over the years as
all these companies were merged into
larger companies
and so there's a lot less risk-taking
that people wanted to do
and it became more of on their part you
know an algorithmic
science what was going to work do you
have the elements how much should the
movie cost and where should it go
um you know in the early in the 80s and
the early 90s
a lot of people would make movies they
knew wouldn't work at the box office
because they were prestigious for the
studio
and a lot of good movies got made that
way you know every once in a while you
find out a movie is a humongous hit that
you never thought would work
and you got a lot of experimentation and
some really interesting movies that way
so some of that is no longer part of the
business although
some of those movies now get made
independently but we all know the
independent movie business has become
more difficult too
because a lot of that financing is dried
up and a lot of the companies that make
those movies
kind of got out of business what hasn't
changed uh is
a producer a producer who uh
can get the important people on the
phone is
you know that that's the guy who's
getting movies made and i you know john
and i've been working together for
over a decade now and i'm always
astonished
at his ability to get literally anybody
on the phone
it is it is a super power and a lot of
producers pretend
like they can get the fancy person on
the phone john
gets the fancy person on the phone
because he knows them he went to their
kids bar mitzvah he's had him over for
dinner
he's always i mean john literally knows
everybody in town
and that is not an exaggeration i was at
jason reitman's bar mitzvah
he was very good i was at freddy
savage's bar mitzvah
he was very good it's true everybody
adam sandler wandered into our office
one day he didn't know it was our office
right john he wandered in he wanders
right into john's office i'm sitting in
there having a chat about something
in walks adam sandler and john says adam
hey you were you made a video for my
kids bar mitzvah
right rajon and adam's like it's true
yeah i remember that
i mean i was there i look i got to go
hang out with
bruce willis late at night i wasn't even
making his movie
but my wife and i she's like eight
months pregnant
and he said why don't you come over and
just shoot craps with me and i said all
right my wife and i went over to his
trailer
and the middle of the night and we shot
perhaps it was great
i really hope that you've kept some sort
of journal along the way
uh just because my god i can't imagine
the stories
i really can't this you could do a whole
i'm telling you you can do a
podcast on john's story he has the
greatest
stories my favorite stories and i won't
tell you now because i'll only bore you
are my math out lemon stories when i did
those five movies with those guys
yeah again there's uh when you've made
as many movies as you've made
there's the abundance of story look at i
i could
dig so deep on some of these things but
i want to get into jungle cruise
because i also have questions after
jungle cruise how long have you actually
been attached
how long have you been trying to make
jungle cruise
uh we so we brought the pitch we brought
an
original story our our we had put
together a story we brought it to
disney six years ago about six years ago
uh they liked it and they said can you
get a movie star and uh we reached out
to dwayne i made a movie with dwayne
years and years ago
so we kept in touch and um and uh we
reached out to him he read uh he read
the story
got back to us i i want to say like
within 24 hours
and he said i love it i'm in i've always
wanted to play the jungle cruise captain
i'm in and he he personally called sean
bailey
that day and said i'm your captain let's
go let's do this and then john davis
because because he can get anybody on
the phone he knows alan horn
and he called alan horn and had that
conversation and
that we were off to the races by the way
he's a lovely lovely man
alan horn he really is and sean bailey
really is a terrific terrific president
um
because he was a producer and a writer
and so working with somebody that really
understands all those elements of the
business enables you to work quicker
and better and makes projects really
great john bailey is the sharpest
creative executive
i i've ever worked with in my career uh
he just continually made the movie
better
i actually i know shawn uh i got to meet
him
a while ago and uh he produced tron
legacy so
exactly and uh uh there's a lot of
stories there but
so you guys get dwayne involved um
the thing about dwayne is his schedule
is like fills up
two years out like his scheduling is
very very hard so talk a little bit
about the challenges
of actually shooting this movie with his
schedule
well it was really easy because i'm
going to tell you what happened
so we get them attached and we get a
script
and we have a script that everybody
loves relatively quickly
takes us about a year maybe 14 months
which is really fast
right um and then
sean says let's all go over to ballers
he's shooting on ballers let's bring him
the script
and bring him a gift so we show up walk
onto the sets not even our show
with gifts and a script and he and we
kind of sneak in
you know everybody's looking at us what
are you doing on our set
and we chat with him and he goes thanks
for the gifts and they were lovely
disney-bound books
the history of disney and i mean the
books were like huge coffee table books
right probably
300 books they were really magnificent
get come over with like two or three
of them right he reads the script
and calls us monday and says i'm in and
so then it was just
really getting a director that everybody
liked
and getting a start date and it really
went
fast yeah none of us expected you know
um coronavirus and so that took up
two years of the process right it feels
like in the movie coming out
um even though or maybe at least it took
up 18 months of the process
but it went really well and fast and and
dwayne loved the director idea that john
and i went to him with the studio loved
it
it was a it was not an obvious idea
but if you saw the movie it ended up
being the right idea
i so i'm curious talk a little bit one
of the things that i really enjoyed
about the movie is
the nods to the ride especially the
opening of the movie
it's it's so connected um was that
always in the script can you sort of
talk about that balance of
making it so people that enjoy the ride
can find that kind of stuff in the movie
okay so here's the background and i'll
let john fill it in i'll start it
we both um went on that ride
multiple times we both went to
disneyland as kids multiple times two
and a half
billion people across all the disney
parks have been on that ride it is one
of the most visited rides in the history
of disney dwayne
john and myself and sean bailey quite a
crazy team
went to a secret building in burbank
that houses all of the vaulted
ideas original sketches ideas and
thoughts of walt disney it is a vault i
mean it's it's the archives
and and it's you know it's like it's
like the uh it's like the warehouse at
the end of raiders i mean it's like
you just you can't but nobody nobody
knows where it is nobody can access it
and we we were so lucky they brought us
there and we go in there
and every single sketch for the ride
every single sketch for disneyland you
know things he
doodled ideas you know and then you saw
them come to life
we spent hours in there and it was like
insane we kind of thought that disney
was a cryogenic tube in there also
we weren't sure right he was being
preserved in that room
and it was so secret right and we went
through all these layers of security to
even get in there
right it was like weird i thought it was
like going into the
cia safe house basically the
imagineering people came in with us
and it was the synergy of how do we make
the movie fit the ride
and how do we make the ride fit the
movie because what you're going to see
is what happened is the ride's been
engineered to some degree based on the
movie
yeah no totally and we walked away we
walked away from that experience feeling
uh an intense um obligation
you know to honor the ride and honor
walt's vision for it we we got to see
walt's vision for it
we got to see the original sketches we
got to see what you know what he was
kind of
vomiting out you know and it was uh
it was just extraordinary see we left
feeling like you have to honor
you must honor that but then also you
know walk that fine line of building out
the story building out the mythology
um you know and and and and delivering a
cinema
a big cinematic experience and then on
the way out of that building they go
would you guys like to stay a few
moments and join us for lunch
and it's like what would you like to
join us for lunch we'll bring all the
imagineers in with you
they take us into this dining room which
is this spectacular dining room
in this secret building in this
warehouse that is gorgeous
huge gorgeous dining room and we sit
down
and we all start talking and they start
bringing in waves of food
it was surreal yeah um
when did you realize that what day in
your life did you realize you struck the
lottery
that day that was the day i mean that
that was
the day all of it even dwayne and
dwayne's had access and met
he's met everyone had access to
everything even he was just like
holy [ __ ] like this is this is
incredible
yeah i mean we all felt so lucky to be
there
and and i'm sure they'll never never let
us back but
but it was it was amazing uh you
mentioned that the scripting went very
fast and it was a fast
thing to put together what i love
learning about the changes that go on
behind the scenes
so was there ever a radically different
version of this can you talk about alt
versions of what this movie almost was
the first draft from picara um love
those guys
they did the first draft and they laid a
template they had the characters
uh they had the basic story they had the
basic mythology
um it was a fun draft there and there
are still scenes um
and many ideas from their script that uh
that have made it into the final
and the final product um we then brought
in payne and mckay
uh fantastic writers great guys um and
they actually
wrote the green lit draft the draft that
dwayne signed on to
and that the studio green lit in
arbitration they ended up not getting
credit
um but they those those guys they they
did a tremendous amount of work and they
did great work but they
they worked within the template that was
laid by requ and focara they came in and
just began to kind of
reinvent some set pieces change a
character here and there
um and then from there once we were
greenlit we brought on michael green
and michael came in and um added such
specific wonderful dialogue and
characterization
um and i believe it was michael who
changed um
who changed jack to her brother um right
i think it was michael who made that
change might have been painted mckay my
memory
it's been it's been a few years now um
but michael really was the one who
brought it you know he brought it to the
finish line and he was with us through
production
justin hey also came in for a little bit
of work
um did some good work on it but michael
kind of saw it through
to to the end listen you guys clearly
spent some money making this thing but
no matter how much money you have
and no matter how much time you have
you're it's never going to be enough
so talk a little bit about maybe what
ended up did anything end up getting
cut that was very close to being made
due to
whatever reason don't know i mean
you know we we simplified certain parts
of the movie to simplify the mythology
just so that you know it was easier your
first time through the movie to digest
right when you when you know the script
really well and you know the movie
really well
you know it's possible that you can go
down that
um that hole of you know making the
mythology so complicated and cool and
intricate
that you know you'd have to see the
movie three times to kind of get
and so we didn't want that you know to
you know be in the way of a fresh
audience seeing the movie and being able
to absorb it all
so we simplified that mythology a lot um
especially in the end
um you know but i can't say
that we really cut any big chunks of the
movie
john no no we didn't we didn't there
wasn't anything that we had kind of
conceived and then at the last minute
for budget reasons had to
had to uh uh jettison um no i mean it's
all it's all
on screen yeah there wasn't anything
major that we cut i love learning about
how movies are made
and so what do you think might surprise
people to learn
about the making of jungle cruise that
they wouldn't read and press notes they
wouldn't read in the
novelization or whatever advertisements
are coming out
well it'll take the fun away if i say
that so i don't want to do that
but we weren't actually really on the
amazon river
[Laughter]
spoiler alert spoiler yeah
what is something uh you know uh i i
what we built that we built the entire
town
uh in that opening you know in the setup
to the story
we're in that town and um and we built
it
the entire town and i gotta tell you
when you walked when you walked in that
in that bar which is featured in the
movie uh and you walk in the marketplace
where we have that big action set piece
um you know with uh with emily and
dwayne it it i mean you were living it
it was
those i mean they just did an incredible
job and we were
we were in this um kind of uh uh remote
part of kawaii um very muddy
and uh and the working conditions
weren't ideal but
uh the the finished product was i mean
just it transported
you to a different time in place the
magic of movies
never ever ceases to amaze me man i mean
the fact that we created
something out of nothing the thing that
always like the movie when i see it
you know and i know where it was made
that it just overwhelms me
that it was shot or a shot but black
panther was shot in the lamp of the
entire movie
yeah visual of visual effects nowadays
this actually leads me to a question i
wanted to ask you guys
so i'm not sure if either of you are
watching the mandalorian but they use
that technology
yeah i mean the show's fantastic
it's really cool so the the volume
technology that they're using is now
spreading throughout the world there's
now in london
they're they're developing and
everything they're wearing they're
working on a movie that's used we can't
tell you yet the movie
but we're well into a movie um where
um we've researched the stages we know
where they are
we're we're in early prep and
that technology is going to be perfect
for us
and it's really going to allow us to
take a fairly
you know simple story but it all takes
place
you know um in an airplane right
um and we're gonna be able to
put the entire movie except for maybe an
end scene the beginning scene
on a stage and because of the way that
technology works
we're going to be able with um you know
a really sophisticated director
shoot the entire movie in 20 days
yeah if i knew what the movie was and
the director would be able to
ask more on that but i i think that that
technology is really
uh and i hate the term game changer but
it it is
i think that works absolutely it's a
complete game it's a complete game
changer and we're seeing the kinds of
things you can do with it i mean you
just have to go up spend a couple of
months beforehand shooting your plates
right and processing them and then you
just go and you're in that world the
whole movie's in that world i mean it's
insane
there's a new volume stage it's opening
up in atlanta babelsburg now
uh has built out i think multiple stages
yeah i mean it's it
it's it is a game changer it is the next
wave in filmmaking
yeah no 100 um uh at what point
in the making of jungle cruise did you
realize you were making something that's
going to turn out really cool
we really felt like
when we got the director on board we
heard his vision
right because jama brought a lot to this
movie
right and he was the one that figured
out the look
and the lore of the conquistadors and it
was really cool the way he
visualized them and saw them coming to
life
once we had dwayne on board the
director's vision
set we were hopeful it was going to be
great
call it self-loathing but i never think
anything i do is cool while making it
because i'm always thinking oh my god
we've [ __ ] it up like we've
we've [ __ ] it up how can we make it
better i mean i i mean even after the
movie's done it's like you look and you
go it's it's good but you all you see is
like where it could have been a little
bit better you know
and uh but i guess that's just well it's
like curse
you know it's like when john and i made
dolomite
right it's like we make the movie
and and we see the first cut and we go
like
this is really cool did we just make a
movie just for ourselves
right do we just you know spend 45
million dollars
just making a movie for ourselves and
eddie that we just like
is our like you know kind of little
project
just ours right is anybody actually
gonna
kind of understand that what we did is
is kind of funny and cool and
interesting this was a real guy
this is a cool journey and and then we
started showing the movie and we like
oh yeah people really like this yeah but
i have a wife who's always telling me
cut it out
like it's good just embrace it that it's
good the problem is that
uh as someone who's and you guys you
guys know this
sometimes you can have an amazing movie
and it does nothing
and sometimes you can have a movie that
you're like i don't know if this turned
out well and it's a huge hit
of course no rhyme or reason no remember
i'm basically out of time but i do want
to know what are you excited at your
company
for projects that are on the cusp or
things that maybe
you want to tease i am here for it well
i'll tease you just a little bit
so we're making a movie at sony
that i love that harkens
back to where i spent a lot of time in
this
business right making you know
family movies um and it's harold the
purple crown
and it's carlos sendano and it's going
to be
zac levi and the script is
amazing it's these two amazing writers
um why am i blanking on their name
johnny help me real quick handleman and
guillen
hannel and young are just brilliant
writers
um you know written this from beginning
to end
and we're going to start shooting
november we think it can be great we're
also going to start shooting a movie
called the
uglies based on scott westerfield's book
series
you know um and um
you know my wife jordan bugged me seven
years ago
eight years ago maybe he was 15 now
saying this is my favorite series i've
read it to our daughters
you know we have to do this and so it's
only taken
a 15-year journey from four different
studios and two different networks
and finally found its way to um netflix
we did sell 20 new movies during the
pandemic that's true
so that's true and made for tv shows and
yeah we were happy
and so we yeah so we have 20 new
projects and so we have musicals
because we've gone musical crazy we have
science fiction
we have comedy we have r-rated comedy
we have some family movies i have one
actual final question for you uh even
though there's a
thousand other things from license to
drive to you name it
but i am curious um the blacklist has
you guys produced the blacklist hugely
successful show
radical change just happened on the
finale of this season
how long now that it's into season eight
contracts
i'm sorry contracts by now really have
to be redone and you've made a radical
change
to the cast is this one of these shows
that you see going like
many more years or is it now at this
point where it's year to year
it's year to year but it could go for
many more years
listen james would keep doing it forever
and he has made that clear he'll keep
doing it forever
he loves the character loves just
digging in you know
to his his his his world uh
and and the showrunner uh john
eisendrath uh
he'd continue doing it forever as well
so if we're lucky enough to get the uh
to get nbc to continue saying yes
why not why not and by the way i know
i'm biased but i think the show
creatively in the last two years
has has been uh as good as it gets on
broadcast television think it's been i
know
i know i'm biased but truly uh i think
these guys
uh have done an exceptional
job with the storytelling um so just as
a as a fan i'm excited to see
what uh what what season nine holds and
the fact that this cast
hung in with us for eight years i mean
for eight years
literally all the original cast hung in
with us that's phenomenal to get
somebody to hang in that long i watch it
because of james i think he's just such
a talented actor
and i do love his character on it friend
it was fun you have so much
energy and enthusiasm and excitement
this is a joy
absolute pleasure